WE GET TO GOALTE
YOU GOTTA GOSTISBEHERE.
CAPOBI FLYING.
TANGLED UP IN ATINST THE
COYOTES AS WELL THINK AS GOOD
TAGE THOMPSONUT HIGH AND THEY WT
AROUND. THE SABRESES
TOUCHED THE PUCK ON THE POWER
PLAY IMPORTANT.
YOU GOTTA HAVE THEM OR ATIGHT AU
WANT THE PUCK IN THE
SCHMALTZ COMES THIS NOT GO IN
THE BACK OF THE
>> Matt: STRALMAN.
AND NOWNING IN THE
OPENING PERIOD.
TULONG.
BOYD IS IN CAN'T FINISH IT OFF S
KREBS WILL SET ITRE NATIONAL HOY
CAPOBIANCO.
NOW KELLER.
COYOTETEAY HE COULD LIGHT
IT.
>> Tyson: BACK IN TENTS 18 HE
HAD THAT 40-GOAL OUT,
ALEX TUCK, RACING UP.
JOKIHARJU HAS IT.THE SPEED CUTSN
A CROSS, T TOO. JUICY REBOUND, .
>> Matt: WE'LL SEE WHAT UNFOLDS,
PAUL BISSONNETE ON THE SET WITH
JODY JACKSON BETWEEN PERIODS AW.
>> Matt: BACK OUT GOOD.
THE 40-YEAR-OLD GOALTENDER.
WAS PEPPERED EARLY IN THIS FIRST
PERIOD.
KESSEL. LIVE.
GOSTISBEHERE,, KELLER. TWO.
>> Matt: KELLER BACK OUT HIGIG
ANDERSON.
FISCHER HAD A COUPLE OF GOOD